I believe in life it's not white it's
not black it's always gray there's metal
zone for everything I believe Alif wait
for look yeah sometime after our journey
I'm gonna live wait but I'm not doing it
because I'm gonna punch harder or I'm
gonna be stronger I'm doing because it
has nothing to do with it I come back
not because it's easy what I'm doing
what I'm gonna attempt I do it because I
come back because it's hard need
motivation
what's a top 10 with pity's nation
what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack and chew in today's lessons
from a man who went from being bullied
in school growing up and learning karate
to defend himself to working as a
bouncer and garbage man to pay his bills
to becoming one of the greatest MMA
fighters of all time
he's George st. Pierre and here's my
take on his top ten rules of success
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be confident I believe people are
bullied because of the image that they
they projected when I was young I had a
lot of a big lack of confidence and in
my school where I used to go there
either the lincoln teenager they used to
pick on the younger kids they were sent
there because they used to that problem
with their family raised by single
father or mother like alcoholic
somewhere or orphan and you know they
grew up in a bad environment with a lot
of violence so the only way of
communication they had it was true
violence and they used to apply that to
the younger kid in school and I was
victim of that unfortunately so so that
thing is that when I go to do conference
the people why why you get bully
sometimes is because the image you
project if you look down raise their
shoulder and look like a weakling in
like in nature the lion will always go
for the animal who's weak whose injure
in same thing in society the people will
bully that easy target and when I was
young had a big problem with confidence
you know I used to people look down you
know I didn't have older brother or
older cousin to defend myself I was by
myself you know and I got picked on
because I was an easy target like this
so what martial art taught me is to
stand up straight when I look I talked
to people I look in the eye when I shake
hand I'm firm and the way I start to
carry myself the body language transform
me it's that I stop being bullying not
because I start beating up people right
just because I the way I was starting to
act the way I was starting to the the
projection that I give to people change
and that's what makes it stop it's not
about being tall now it's about
presenting an and an image look tough
and look confident look confident
that's about same thing in business same
thing when you go ask a girl on a date
absolutely good I am sorry I am I don't
want to bother you but please could you
think you could come with me it's
Saturday night so Darrell you know like
it wouldn't work you know like they ask
you for a look like a loser you don't
you have to be for you know confident
guy you know rule number
to find balance you know I remember when
you brought with how do you say his last
name is Garbowsky
so John shouts got muskie yeah when you
brought him to work with you on the
Ultimate Fighter and he would be
partying all night drunk and show up at
the gym the next day and still everybody
up yeah
and did that influence your this your
idea about just be more relaxed in
training and just not worrying about it
as much yeah but he's a different like
it's a total different extreme you know
like like I don't believe in that
extreme but Charlie yeah I remember the
producer of the show The Ultimate
Fighter when he was about he was
supposed to stay one week and when he
was about to say the producer was
telling me hey can we keep him for the
rest of their show because it was a good
TV so like I don't know I'm gonna ask
him and in the same time like a lot of
the people on my team they were like man
okay that's enough now we got what we
need and I was like yeah I like
everybody's is kind of a you know I need
to kind of babysit him in the same time
but yeah the knowledge that this guy had
and he gave us was just a big big edge
you know and but I shall is a different
extremer Joe I think there is a a
central line that you need to keep you
know
that's what I believe I believe in life
it's not white it's not black it's
always great there's metal zone for
everything I believe rule number three
be efficient there's one thing I don't
believe in the string conditioning I
don't and I never do some conditioning I
don't I do not believe that doing a
running on a treadmill or doing I don't
know what so-called machine I don't
believe that's gonna help you will have
a better cardio during the fight I think
everything in fighting is about
efficiency so you don't do strength and
conditioning as far as like hitting
tires with sledge and ever did in my
life I remember my instructor from
France Josh asked our bus key that I
brought even on the reality show The
Ultimate Fighter the guys smoke I don't
know how many pack of cigarette today is
always drinking alcohol he's a real
character and he's completely out of out
of shape but when you spar with with us
in Muay Thai you kick everyone's ass the
reason is because it's more efficient
than we are in the UFC I do believe
everyone is in shape we're all athlete
you know we all have a maximum vo2 max
that we can reach but I believe the
reason why a guy is more tired than
another guy is because one guy is more
efficient than the other one guy is is a
is able to bring the fight where is is
the strongest and the other guy worries
is taking he's out of his comfort zone
the only reason why it's good to lift
weight
I do believe do bench press and stuff
like that I believe it's because it's
gonna make me more marketable is gonna
keep myself more symmetric have a better
image which is very important because if
you look good you feel good and you feel
good you do good so it's it's nothing
wrong with that you know if weight for
looks yeah Alif wait for look yeah I'm
gonna admit that sometime after our
journey I'm gonna live weight but I'm
not doing it because I'm gonna punch
harder or I'm gonna be stronger I'm
doing because it has nothing to do with
it I'm doing it because I want to be you
know like a good shape and when I do it
for myself
rule number four my personal favorite
help others when I was bullied I didn't
enjoyed it I make joke about it I have a
very good record as a MMA professional
fighter but if you go in my bully time
losing record I got beat up pretty bad
that many times still be on the wrong
yeah it was on the wrong side exactly
but it's normal I was young and I was
going up against guys that are older
than me and and they were ganging up on
me and it's alright you know like but as
a matter of fact a funny story about
this is a the other day at like a few
months ago I was on the street and I I
saw one of the guy that that used to
bully me I was about to ask have you I
did I did saw him and he was begging in
the street like and and I saw him what
one day he was begging in the street I
swear like homeless yes like like I
don't know if it was all me but he was
asking for money
woman and then when he saw me he
recognized me and I know he saw me on TV
and everything and I told him I don't
want to mention his name for for him it
but I said is that what are you doing
here like can you help me things are not
going well I'm like man what you doing
here you're tall guy you're good-looking
what the hell you're good shape so I
give him a dollar a few few dollar you
know and I ten was I get out of here man
it should be a shame you should be
embarrassed of what you're doing man you
you're a lot of guy that would kill to
be like you you know you're full of
potential like good looking man LT tall
and strong as I kidding go do something
with your life and apparently like up to
very recent like a month ago he went to
my house where my parents live he knock
at my at the door he second I talked to
George my dad says George doesn't live
there anymore you know he goes well I've
met him in a few month ago and he says
something to me to shake me up and I
just want to say that he changed my life
now I have a job and I'm doing well and
and I want to say thank you to him if
you see one you say thank takes
tell him I say thank you and it we were
all hoping the story I did with you
punch me with a face but then I realized
that the guy the guy I used to bully me
he bully me not bad that's bad but you
ruling me because he probably been
bullied by his dad growing up like by
you you only been raised with this
single dad that was an alcoholic beating
and beating him up so is his way of
conversation was to beating up people so
he was doing to me what his dad was
doing to him
so it made me realize on life sometime
you you you see people you think they're
a bad person it's not their bad person
is their their a natural environment
make them act in a certain way you know
there's no one not because a bad person
so it'd make me made me think a lot
about but whoa rule number five commit
fully mom told us that when you were 9
or 10 years old you were walking around
one entire summer on your hands because
it was something you were working on
when you commit to something man you
commit to it if unless you were walking
upstairs you're walking around the
entire house on your hands yeah I uh
yeah I'm obsessive compulsive you know
like when I want to obtain something I
become complicit completely obsess about
it your mom also tells a story about you
being at home and seeing on a commercial
or on a television show a Hulk Hogan
doll and you stood up on the couch you 9
or 10 years old and he said with enough
conviction to give your mom chills that
someday there's going to be a George st.
Pierre at all and and and you knew that
as a kid and she said I believed him
because that's how much he was he was
definitive about that yeah yeah it was a
big WWE wrestling fans you know I used
to play with all these dolls you know
and yeah I said that's my mom because I
was very close like I didn't I dad a lot
of doubt of my mind but I knew that I
was going to going to the extreme to
obtain what I wanted to I was like
that's part of my my OCD you know rule
number six respect your opponents every
time I step into the Octagon my
well-being is on the line and yes I'm
scared I'm not I'm not afraid to say it
someone who said is doesn't he's not
afraid he's because he's a liar or is
he's a little bit crazy how did you
change the way you view dealt with fear
you become older and more confident you
need to know yourself know your opponent
know with I guess with who you dealing
with and you need also to respect his
strength but not fair it you know like
Josh Koscheck I've been analyzing him a
lot I wish
spec him I respect what he's good at you
know there is a strong point but I'm not
scared of it
rule number seven be the maestro I am a
little bit the head guy in a way you
know I believe as a fighter you need to
be the head guy you'reyou're the maestro
we'll have the people that work like
with you and and but you need to know
how to use these people good for
instance I I don't know nothing about
business but I have agents that are
there to negotiate Friday they'd knows
number they know about investment I have
one another guy who knows about
physicality he's a he's a lawyer and is
good for a tax report I don't know
nothing but I know how to get the good
people to help me for that bradster
thing right rule number eight do the
hard things I'm better than I was when I
left off and my trainer believe I'm
better than then I was when I left off
when your champion for so long you carry
a lot of people sometime over that the
year you realize a lot of the people are
fake people because they live off to you
but I'm smart enough to find out who's
who and you know like a lot of a lot of
the people in my rush I might they're my
friend and my close friend so I trust
their trust they're they're what they're
gonna tell me and if they tell me I
don't think you should have got back
that will tell me they would have told
me and we all on the same page here I
know I'm the best I've ever been but
finding is a different thing I I come
back not because it's easy what I'm
doing when I'm gonna attempt I do it
because I come back because it's hard
and that's what makes it better for me
because it's hard and it's only a few
people have been able to do it
and if I do it and if people think it's
impossible for me to do it but if I do
it that's mean I'll be the first to do
with them be I'll be very very happy and
makes it unique for me rule number nine
have a strong mind how much of your your
training is dedicated to visualization
fighting it there is a big science
behind it I believe I'm I'm I'm Campion
not because I'm the strongest guy not
because also under the more skilled guy
I'm very skilled I'm very strong I'm
very athletic I'm fast but I think the
reason why I'm champion is my mind
my eye I'm very good to using my skills
to neutralize my open and skill and and
make the fight turning to putting the
odds on my side I think there's a key
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is don't
overthink things because I all fighting
is my Nam and fighting is not my life
man my life is my family man is my
friend the people I love this is what I
do in my life is not my life I didn't if
fighting is over it's over all right
turn around do something else you know
what I mean like is what I do in my life
some my life you know what I mean
it's at the end of the world man is more
to life than fighting whoo it's funny
hearing that from you because you would
expect to hear that from someone who
isn't considered one of the greatest of
all time but you're considered one of
the greatest of all time so it would be
very art it would be very hard to argue
your approach because it's been so
successful they they they got it have to
be super obsessed I'm super obsessed Joe
but that's why I become crazy then I
stop for four years then and when I came
back I some of my circuit and the brain
then I start to analyze myself and like
why I'm why become crazy why did I stop
because I'm taking this stuff too
seriously man you have to take it for
what it is you know yeah it's a world
championship fight I'm fighting I was
fighting Michael bliss me after four
years people oh my god the fight are
promoted on drama
yeah like John said John dinar he says I
fight are not won on drama are won or on
mundane things that we do every day yeah
that's how fight are one yeah how you
program program your your your crews
your your your your crews driver you
know your your your autopilot to win the
fight that's how you you may I see it I
fight like a autopilot you know like so
when I fight when I prepare myself for a
fight especially for the tactical part I
program like a computer ow
I want to react against that specific
problem oh I'm gonna take care that that
specific problem the only way to program
it is to do
repetition repetition and repetition and
repetition and repetition it's like he
said the one point the Bravo we said
like tie tying tying up your shoes yes
we've been doing it so many time you can
talk to someone the same thing yes when
I get into a fight I analyze again and
I'm fighting and I see what pattern he
does the most often so I want to program
my computer to react to that pattern
that would give me the advantage into
the fight I don't know when that pattern
when occur when I want to program myself
that when I cure I have an answer for it
right away I don't have to think about
it I don't think I just react and that's
my problem when I used to fight and I
got a lot of criticism before I was
thinking too much towards the end of my
career had so much pressure I didn't
perform as well as I was earlier the
especially my last fight before I
stopped for the four years I was
thinking too much over thinking to
putting too much pressure like you says
too serious you have to take it for what
it is it's only a fight in a 10 years
you know it's you know it sucks if you
lose but man it is what it is you know I
mean don't take it for don't make it
bigger than what it is
I've got a bonus GSB clip on how to
learn to handle pressure but before that
I want to know question the day which of
these two clips did you prefer help
others or do the hard things let me know
in the comments below
help others who do the hard things thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clip
you the guy George becoming GSP does
that that becomes overwhelming like
everyone looks you a certain way and
you're treated like a celebrity to the
point that it gets overwhelming I mean I
explained to you that in my word the way
to describe it and that's the reason why
I believe it's hard to become champion
but it's even harder to stay champion
and that's why a lot of young guy when
they get champion they can't man they
cannot maintain the belt for a long time
because when you become champion
everybody wants you you become the
target everywhere you go they talk about
you it become like an illusion that the
whole world is watching you no matter
what you do it's all about you you you
and it's become like completely insane
so a trick that I gave myself when I was
like falling almost cracking under
pressure is I remember a few days before
a fight what I like to do is take my car
and go drive on the street and I used to
look at people in the street like I used
to see for example two days before my
fighters take my car and I saw that old
lady carry her grocery bag and I'm
thinking I'm like she doesn't know me
she doesn't care about me no matter what
happened Saturday night she doesn't care
and I see this other guy with his son in
the park he doesn't care about me so you
need some time you lose that reality
because you're so much involved into it
and our sport is not like a regular
sport it's not like tennis if you lose
on tennis you lose if you lose and
fighting game you might lose some brain
cell and and that will affect your your
well-being so it's a it's a pure deep
survival instinct that's that checked in
so it's more than a sport it's a it's a
it's a fighting game it's you say you
play tennis you play baseball play
football but you cannot play fighting so
all that add to that make it a lot more
stressful so that's why a lot of people
they crack under pressure
but you need to find ways that
therapeutically therapeutically release
you from it if you tell yourself a story
long enough you start to believe it
I have Tulsa what a whale out of
handcuffed lightning though Thunder in
jail now you know I'm bad over the last
week I murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between eighteen
and two hundred and fifty four days of
taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 254
confidence or every single day for 254
days I will be sending you a video
between thirty seconds and five minutes
long that you start your morning with
around making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access